a day of relative calm along temporary
avenues of escape
war came suddenly to the people of
ukraine getting away from it is much
harder from cities like sumi in the
north where residential buildings were
struck overnight
and from energy in the east
even from mariopol in the south among
the most embattled of all their fleeing
scenes like this the remains of a
maternity hospital another inexplicable
tragedy in conditions the red cross
describes as apocalyptic
for many civilians still trapped in the
ruins of their cities there is no
respite
nor for medical teams in hospitals where
the injured arrived daily
how are you little
the doctor asks i am fine replies the
boy following surgery to remove a bullet
from the base of his skull
we have operated on four children and
sadly one little girl has died
in an arc of smaller towns close to the
capital kiev the great escape continues
on foot much of it here from places like
butcher and urpin where a distraught
toddler can't bear to let go of the
father who must stay behind and defend
the town
[Applause]
and from hostimel and makarev where 13
people died on sunday cueing for bread
trends
these are very difficult times for
ukraine for our city but european stands
erpin holds the defense
they've managed to get not to safety so
much as the comfort of the capital the
still standing symbol of what it once
meant to live in a sovereign country
and what they're determined it will mean
again as the kiev symphony orchestra
plays a concert for peace
not far away is chernobyl a symbol of
something much darker nuclear
catastrophe now in russian hands a power
cut to the plant's defunct reactors and
radioactive waste facilities signaled
ukrainian alarm
the un's atomic agency though says
there's no critical impact on safety
satellite images show the concentration
of russian forces on the outskirts of
the capital
there can be little doubt that at some
point fortified and resupplied they may
try to overrun these outer suburbs
this is a moment as president zielenski
described it of maximum threat
and getting ready to counter it are
these trainee fighters who what seems
like only yesterday were film students
or i.t workers their old lives now on
hold
russia may have superiority in terms of
numbers but ukraine has deep reserves
men between the ages of 18 and 60 who've
been told they must remain in the
country in case they're needed to fight
but first they must be taught how
max is 20 a musician and music
journalist whose band echoes british
prog rock legends like marillion and
king crimson i was born here and i need
to protect it
so
i hope all of my friends will be safe
and in the end after the
end of the war we will meet again have a
beer
just have fun and relax
it takes a special kind of optimism to
believe those carefree days will soon be
back joe nahal al jazeera